News stories predict a “retirement crisis”
of inadequate retirement savings.
In response, progressives have proposed expanding
Social Security benefits and establishing
new retirement plans run by state governments.
Americans are worried, and many pine for the
days of traditional pensions.
But the data tell a very different story.
Far more Americans are saving in 401(k)s today
than ever had a traditional pension.
Contributions as a percent of salaries have
risen by one-quarter since 401ks were introduced,
and total retirement savings have tripled.
IRS data show that the typical retiree today
has an income higher than when he was working.
Retirees are half as likely to live in poverty
as working-age households.
And rather than running out of money, the
typical retiree’s net worth increases as
he gets older.
The real crisis is in Social Security and
state and local government pensions, which
are underfunded by up to 26 trillion dollars.
Sure, 401ks needs tweaks.
But I’ll trust my retirement to the system
that’s working, not to government-run plans
that are short by trillions.
What do you think about retirement savings?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.